[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm Dave Ramsey your host
Ken Coleman number one bestselling
author host of the Ken Coleman show
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
thank you for joining us America the
number is
[Music]
88255 225
88255 225 Scott starts this hour in
Springfield Illinois hey Scott welcome
to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave it's an honor to be talking
to you and Ken um I I appreciate you
guys and what you do and um I'll get
right to my question okay so I don't
hold you guys up um my question is me me
and my wife and my five kids uh we we
have a 40 Acre Farm and a log cabin that
we just recently sold it's under
contract we signed the papers January
19th what we're looking to do is with
the cash we get from that we plan on
building uh a new place over on an acre
and a half that we were gifted and we're
trying to figure out where to put the
money and why we build and the build
would start you know January 19th
closing so more or less we
would I try to be in there by September
1st is the goal to have everything done
and built I'm being general contractor
um and just trying to figure out where
we can put that money to have best
access to it you're going to use the
money to build
with yes use the money uh we have no
debt we have no we have no debt at all
we are our farm and and cab everything
we have now thanks to you guys so if I'm
understanding you you're going to use up
the majority of the money by
September yes correct correct so you're
going to draw down on it beginning
almost
immediately and you know as you put in
footings and start to lay block and uh
start to order your Lumber package which
is as you know is your one of your big
ticket items so I mean in the first 60
days you're going to come out of pocket
with a
ton right yes correct correct yes that's
how building budget works so yeah um I
would just lay out your budget and you
know high yield savings account a money
market is something like that it doesn't
matter because you're not going to have
the money in there basically you're
going to have the equivalent of half
this money in there for nine months 3/4
of a
year so if something's paying 5% you're
going to make the equivalent of 2% or 2
and a half% to down about 1 and a half%
so uh net net net is the net that's the
net dollars you're going to earn because
you're only going to be in there nine
months and only half the money is going
to be in there because you're going to
be drawing down on it through there you
follow me yes yes sir so what you my
point is what you earn on it doesn't
matter much having solid access to it
does and having it in a separate account
that you nickname building fund does so
high yield savings account money market
with check writing privileges that's
fine so you can write your checks and
pay your bills right okay yes cuz I cuz
what I'm see around here is I'm seeing
like
4.5 yeah on I saving but it's again
you're not going to make 4.5 because
you're not going to be in there a whole
year with the whole pile pile of
money okay you understand if you're
taking it out a if let's say you took it
out over 12 months the average would be
half the pile through the 12 months you
follow me yes sir and so the average
would be half of 4 and a half% net that
you're actually making on the pile so um
the the the point of all that is when
you add up the actual ual dollars it's
not going to be a lot you just want it
safe and you want to be as wise as you
can so the the important thing here is
check writing privileges access to it to
follow the building budget and the cash
flow needed and um you know so a money
market with checkw writing privileges if
at your local bank if you found one four
and a half and they've got check running
privileges to be able to pay the bills
and be able to transfer money to your
Lumber Company and so on then you're
right on track that's exactly what I do
good question man sounds like you're
living the dream congratulations yeah
exciting is is it to hear a young couple
because you can tell he's young and
they're going to cash flow a build and I
think that's pretty amazing that to me
is the American dream I hear all this
stuff all the time oh can we get ahead
and the fan the answer is you can but
you got to be disciplined you got to be
debt free because he's got lots of
options Jim is in Hawaii hey Jim welcome
to the Ramsey Show hi Dave aloha aloha
what's up
man well I my wife and I are in a
dilemma and we're trying to figure out
if it makes sense for us to sell our
home in paradise and move to Florida
I've got details but I don't want to
give them to you until you're ready so
fire away with your questions to help us
figure this out that's funny Hawaii's
paradise and we got to move to
Florida yeah which Yankees from New York
think Florida's Paradise okay now yeah
who wants to move most so why are you
moving uh primarily for um we could sell
our house for 2.5 and buy a house there
for about 1 five put a million in the
bank we're debt free she's retired I'm
not so we'd save on state income tax put
some money in the bank and earn more
money that way uh local politics kind of
drive us crazy and the cost of living
keeps going up in
Hawai yeah well if that was me I'd be
going to Florida yeah if those were my
answers that'd be enough yeah that that
sounds like I you know like you've got a
lot of math reasons to leave and the sad
thing is Hawaii is wonderful as it is um
is the the third is the number three
state that people are leaving number
one's New York number two is California
and number three is Hawaii and the
reason they're leaving all three of them
are exactly what you've outlined taxes
and
politics financially I don't want to go
back into debt and our the rest of our
money is tied up in other areas so the
only way we could really do it is to
sell and we don't feel emotionally ready
to leave and so we can't find an
emotional way to hook ourselves and
you've been there a long time there's no
Financial solution either than you've
been there a long
time in Hawaii we've been there 15 years
and you didn't leave the state left
you you didn't change that's right I I I
I wonder Jim how many more times you
have to pay those taxes how many more
times you have to see some type of
politics that you just really don't
align with before you're motions do get
ready I got a buddy of mine just moved
out of California and he paid cash for a
house in Nashville he's been in
California his whole life he paid cash
for a house in Nashville with his income
tax savings in one year one year of
income tax savings from California just
getting out he makes a lot of money
obviously but um you know one year's one
year with no California income tax
bought him a cash House in Nashville
that's that's why people are leaving I
mean it's math and it does it does
Pierce through the emot
so I get why you would leave um I also
understand it's a beautiful wonderful
place and um and it's hard to leave home
and it's home for you so uh those are
decisions you guys have to make as a
couple uh the emotional part of it
mathematically I if I'm you I'm gone I
get why my buddy moved out to California
again he paid cash with one years of tax
savings you know it's Bonkers art
laugher tracked this years ago the
states that have an income tax and
particularly High income tax have uh the
highest rate of Exodus yeah and it's
gotten worse and worse and worse every
year in those three states with the
covid policies the when the foui
pandemic hit and um the policies around
that and the crazy politics and the
lawlessness and everything else people
are bailing man it's crazy and it's sad
cuz they're wonderful States the actual
geography is wonderful this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our Health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
budget
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple 8
8255 225 Bethany is with us in Dallas
Texas Hi Bethany how are you hey guys
thanks for taking my call I'm doing
great good how can we help hey so my
husband and I both work for my dad um he
owns a hardware and feed store and um we
you know he's owned it for 16 years so
I've worked on and off just through
middle school and high school um and
then now we both run the store full-time
um we make about 34,00 each a year and
then Ivan my husband makes 19 with um
the VA income and so collectively we
make
87,000 um so instead of a raise the last
few years he has given us um 1% of the
stores um I guess value um if if the
store would ever sell we would get X
percentage of the sell price um and so
right now we have 3% and we so sorry
backstory we're debt free
um we are in the middle of building our
home um and so our home loan total is
292 um we were able to buy the land in
cash um and so we own sorry about an
acre and a half and um everything else
is paid for we have our um six month
savings saved up um and so uh kind of I
guess our big question is we've been
listening to the Ramsey Show and we hear
all these crazy numbers of combined
income and I know you're not supposed to
compare but I do
um and so we live comfortably we have
three kids um we're able to pay all of
our bills with the home loan we're going
to be able to pay that off soon but
whenever you look at our income it's
significantly lower than a lot of people
um and so but we have the the percentage
in the store so the big question is do
we stick with the store to where when
Dad retires in about 10 years we already
have
15% um in it or do we look for something
that has a higher
income
um but then you would we wouldn't own
the store so I don't know we're kind of
we're torn and there's some days that
we're like yeah it's worth it in the
long run and then some days it's like
but man it'd be cool to pay off the
house in three to four years instead of
10 years and I don't know so my question
is what's the long run look like with
real numbers and is it really worth it
I'm not questioning as I don't think it
is I'm asking you if you
what's the store worth why is it worth
it the the store why is it worth it
personally or financially store worth
what's the value of the store if he sold
it today the value of the store today
would be between 2.5 and three million
okay so 1% is
$25,000 right and so this year we would
have three how did you come up with that
value that's what he's gone by um and so
he just did a reevaluation of everything
too and the bank said hey you're we are
worth between 2.5 and three does that
include real estate that includes real
estate and that's just the hardware
store so he also owns like a bed and
breakfast around the corner and Etc well
the question is are you going to get all
of that are you the only
kid the only kid that wants it so my
brother has no interest in any of it and
so he's told but are you gonna have to
buy your brother out of his share
no okay all right so well 25,000
a year on top of 34 or on top of uh that
that that helps your income basically
that's what 1% is worth right correct
yeah so so then you just ask yourself is
that could he hire a
manager a couple of managers for 34,000
a piece plus 25
bonus probably not yeah I don't think so
yeah because it's just me and my husband
that that managed the store and then
there's a couple high school kids that
come and help yeah I mean I don't what
does the store what does the store make
what's the profit on it couldn't tell
you off the top of my head I don't have
the numbers in front of me okay well
hold
on no I'm not going to waste your time
with me that's okay um well I I I'm not
questioning your contentment or the or
whether that's fair or not it it's just
a matter of is this a fair deal to you
and that's really what you're asking and
the Fair Deal to you is the the answer
to that is the math for me is is the I
don't think he's giving you enough
percentage per year to make me excited
if I'm you he needs to up this to 5% a
year to where after 10 years you own
50% okay that makes sense I'd be excited
about
that oh and by the way as I own more
percentage that percentage of the profit
comes to me each year
because I'm one of the owners I don't
own 25% and you keep 100% of the profit
yeah that makes sense so yeah I think
you just need to talk to your dad about
because his intent is not to run you
off right and his intent is not to be
cheap he just hasn't thought it through
and you're going Dad when I think this
through the numbers don't make sense to
us 5% a year would make sense to
us and so you're saying at the end of
the year say we own 3% he should give
you 3% of the profits and 5% of
ownership yeah it's like a dividend
payment gotcha I have a question if you
own 10% You' get 10% of the profits and
you know uh now we're talking that's
fairly
generous you get 10% of the profits and
5% more ownership each year but each
year he bonuses you 5% ownership cuz
then you don't have to buy out I mean I
don't want you 85% having to buy him out
after you've done this enslaved all
these years that doesn't that doesn't
feel right yeah so I have a quick
question on this do you guys want to be
in the in the feed business the hardware
business or do you just want to own your
own
business it's probably a combo of the
two I love the sword and I grew up here
and I love the people and I love serving
the community and that the community is
a big part of it for me and so we from
the beginning it's never been cuz none
of this matters if every day but you
don't hate every yeah that's what I
wanted to know first and I think you're
Dave is absolutely right I think you
guys got to have a money conversation
cuz I'm going to throw this out I'm
curious to know what Dave's going to say
about this I it's not a guarantee that
dad's gonna walk away in 10 years either
it's hard for Founders to walk away so
that to me also that's why I asked that
first question is it really worth it and
what I mean by that question is Dave
addressed it is it worth it year in year
out but I'm also asking is it worth it
15 years from now what could turn into
25 years I just think I think he needs
to give you inwriting that he's done in
10 years he gives you 5% a year and he
pays you your percentage of ownership
and profits every year that's a fair
deal that makes sense he would have to
do that if if it was a third party
coming in to interest them in taking it
managing it for him to get a world class
manager that knows the community and
cares as deeply as you do he would have
to pay that kind of money to get them
that makes sense and um this doesn't
hurt him he's he's in good shape he's
fine yeah we need we need to work
towards that by the way too you need to
add up all this stuff and if it's worth
more than $20 million uh I don't think
it is but if it is you guys need a
detailed estate plan because the
freaking federal government is going to
come take some of it when he dies if you
don't have a good estate plan but a
written game plan that you take over the
store uh byy out the remaining ownership
after 10 years and in the meantime he
gives you 5% a year and in the meantime
your percentage of ownership gets paid
out in profits every year on top of that
and you get paid your salary that's a
fair deal that is not an unfair deal at
all um and it's a good way for him to
not have to pay out cash right now and
it accomplishes his long-term goal which
is to hand off the store so yeah it's um
but if his only income is coming from
this store this is going to be scary for
him I think it is I think this could be
an interesting conversation yeah very
cool so Ken makes a good point those of
us that are founders and I'm one of them
that found a business as we've studied
family business succession planning um
the
hardest move is from generation one to
generation two the founder handing off
is very tough because they're all
wrapped up in it those of us that are
founders are hardheads we're stubborn we
gutted it out and we don't like to let
let go of stuff we like to control stuff
and so it's very hard for us to hand off
to the Next Generation the most
emotional handoff is Gen one to gen two
and the founder it's it's incumbent upon
them to be a grown-up and to count on
the Next Generation taking over this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial peace and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi ref
finances defaulted private student loans
that other places won't touch and gives
you a custom loan built for you based on
your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumpsum payoff option you could qualify
for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America denell Is With Us in Salt Lake
City hi DaNell how are you I'm good
thank you how are you better than I
deserve what's
up I have a little dilemma that we're
trying to figure out what we need to do
I have a 20 12 Hyundai
Elantra and it's got over two 200,000
miles on it um in around the end of
October I was backing up out of a
parking spot and a guy behind me backed
into my car and it didn't ruin my car so
I couldn't drive it but his insurance
totaled my car and great so now
yeah I mean you're driving a hoopie and
you're getting a
check yeah I yeah I can get a check for
it for sure they will I can get 3745 and
keep it and they I'll have to get a
salavage tile no or
4538 no you take the full pay give them
the car go get you a car okay is if the
car was in good shape if the car was in
good shape and it's 200,000 Mile 2012
Elantra what's it actually worth have
you looked it
up yeah it's it's probably under five
well that's what they're giving you is
under five
yeah yeah I want you to make sure that
what they're giving you is the actual
value of the
car well the 45 is what they would give
me and that's what I no honey they're
going to give you the value of the car
that's the
law okay they may not have understood
that yet you may have to help them with
that yeah but they're supposed to give
you the value of the car the guy the guy
tore your car up so um didn't take much
to Total this car but it's okay cool I'm
glad so I I want you guys uh you said we
are you married uhhuh okay you guys jump
on the computer before you accept the
offer and find out from Kelly Blue Book
what the what the uh retail value of
that car is and enter it with 200,000 Mi
no damage and um you know you're the the
attributes of that car the the
accessories it has and so forth and um
and then look on stuff like uh
trader.com and find some that are for
sale that looks SAR in mileage and if
you find out that car is worth 5200 you
call this insurance company up and say
uh you need to pay me 5200 and here's
the appraisal from Kelly Bluebook and
here's three cars on to on trader.com
that look the same and they all these
things say 5200 not 4500 and the guy
will go
okay all right who's the insurance
company Bear River Mutual
what
say it again they're the on River be
River that's the actual insurance
company not they wrote the policy do
what be River mutal okay I just don't
know that one okay all right well I
because sometimes I know their
reputation like if it's State Farm you
can pretty much sure be assured they're
trying to screw you okay yeah that's
it's like their modus operandi
okay I've been hit by State Farm people
twice and it's been a problem both times
okay just a pain in the butt and see it
cost it cost him a lot cuz I just said
that so um but anyway the uh uh anyway
so yeah just just verify that the actual
cost value of the car I'm not trying to
rip them off I want them to pay you what
you're due that's all yeah it's an
honest transaction ding in it I'm sorry
I mean with the ding in the car is that
no darling there wasn't a ding in the
car before he hit it oh okay before he
hit it what was the car worth yeah okay
because that's what they owe you that's
the market value of the car because you
got to take the cash and go buy that
exact car on trader.com from somebody
else that's what you're going to have to
pay for it yeah that's what they should
give you they should replace your car no
you don't keep your
car okay my other question for you then
is this car was almost dead before this
guy put a bullet in it let it die yeah
it's true it's true okay so I have I
have listened to you for years
and I just get sick to my stomach now
thinking about even taking a loan out on
a vehicle well don't bu a $5,000 car put
aside pardon buy a $5,000
car okay you have
$5,000 you were driving a $5,000 car
before this
happened true so it was doing it was
perfectly good with your life or good
enough for now how much money do you
have set aside and is that earmark for
something else or was it for a car
replacement it's it's to go towards a
car replacement about 7,000 7,000 so
then you that that that's your car
fund y okay well then you can buy a
$112,000 car
yeah okay yeah all right I just my
husband wants me to have a car that he
knows we can depend on and he's
like where was his husband before you
got hit in the parking lot he was
sitting next to me I know I know but you
see I'm saying he wasn't he wasn't
whining about you having something that
was Dependable when you're driving this
$5,000
hoopie you were saving up to get out of
the hoopti now you got you sold the
hoopie you just sold it to an insurance
company yep you're right lot of $112,000
cars you can excellent vehicles for 12
Grand excellent a car that'll do any
it'll do double back flips you can get
great cars for 12 Grand yes okay the
best value in the market is 10 to 15,000
it's It's the Best Buy in the car market
you get the most bang for your buck and
uh it's a great you can get a great
vehicle for that that'll last you for a
long time yes yes yes yes yes there's no
reason for you to go in debt hun it's
just it it was an event thank God nobody
was hurt as a little parking lot Ding
and it's just sad that your car the
parking lot ding I never heard anybody
got total in the park in the Kroger
parking lot but there you go so bump
you're total yeah I mean that I was
going to say that was quite a incident
he must have been on his way to the
game with the wings and the chips and
salsa in a hurry something going on
Amber and spoke in Amber welcome to the
Ramsey
show thank you I just have a quick
question actually two-part question um I
have an 18-year-old son he's still in
high school he will be 19 next year
graduating and he is planning on opening
his own business doing what with his
Landscaping with his own money he's not
gonna he's very smart with money he
doesn't have any debt he won't get a
credit card he only uses what he
has
but I was trying to explain to him the
other day that he can do it with a zero
credit score and he and I I am also
confused a little bit too but I know
it's possible so he doesn't want to take
out any loans he's been he doesn't need
a credit score
so why do you need a credit
score I think he's more worried about if
something comes up where he has
to borrow money borrow borrow to yeah if
he has to get a
bigger machine or well that already is
going to come up 100% of the people that
buy machines buy too many of them well
he has a plan to buy used and cash and
if something comes up he'll buy used and
and cash he does not need a credit
score do not use debt as your back stop
in case of emergencies in business
because you will live in debt the rest
of your life because 100% of there's
three rules in business it takes twice
as long as you think it cost twice as
much as you think and you're not the
exception those are the three rules of
business the nice thing is is that he
understands all three of those rules and
he then he doesn't need a credit
score okay the other question is I have
is how I've been trying to get him to
listen
to your show or or read your book or and
he's 18 I'll give him that because he's
just he's still in that mentality stage
where he's 18 and is there
something I don't want to push too hard
so that he doesn't do it all together
but is there I know you have a have
books and programs and stuff like that
but I I've already bought those and he
he wasn't interested in it is it
something that may come along later on
when he's going through I guess is this
I mean the only thing I can tell you is
the only only good I've ever been able
to do with my kids once they turned 18
and Beyond was I Tred try my best to not
use my dad voice cuz once I do they quit
listening I have to use my persuasive
Uncle voice like I'm their uncle that
loves them and has no power because I am
that person that has no power once
they're 18 so you've been using your mom
voice you need to listen to Dave that
won't work he won't he turned that off
immediately use your friend voice and
maybe maybe he'll pick it up probably
not but maybe he will this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show well you've all played the
telephone game the first person Whispers
a message to the second person who
Whispers it to the third and so on
around the table until the original
message has completely changed multiply
that confusion by a 100 if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level netsuite gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us net
week worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America so interest rates on home
mortgages are dropping it's having
a predictable effect just to give you a
little history the 30-year interest
rates um on the 11th of December were
7.1 now they're 6.1 6 .6 the high was 8%
so it's down almost 1 and half% from the
high uh the 15 year on the 11th of
December was
6.5 uh it's sitting right now at uh 6.0
is down a half a percent the high was
7.35 so it's down 1.35 from the high so
interest rates on home mortgages
dropping it's about a 10% drop and uh um
which equals about you know a little
less than 1% drop but not from the high
from just the other day um which is $275
a month on a $400,000 house just to give
you an idea 1% is that's a change so
what we've seen since the day after
Christmas is a huge increase in consumer
demand for mortgages and
agents and we've also seen a similar
increase in the number of Pros Real
Estate Pros trying to become one of our
Ramsey trusted Pros during that time so
all of that means the real estate
Market's coming back to life after a
really cold dark winter yeah it was
pretty much sitting dormant and uh this
little drop it's a 1% basically across
the board uh since in a month that's a
lot um and really 1 and a half% since is
causing people that were sitting on the
sidelines to come back into the market
even some real estate agents that were
kind of waiting I I'll just wait until
spring before I go Selling Houses I
don't know what the flip you people are
doing but anyway with the real ramsy
trusted Pros are people that are people
that sell you know 100 to 300 houses a
year they're they're high octane high
protein real estate agents they're not
your uncle Charlie who got his license
three weeks ago uh and who wants to and
it gets his feelings hurt if you don't
list your $500,000 freaking house with a
new
which would be the definition of dumb
okay so we don't we don't hire Uncle
Charlie as one of our Ramsey trusted
Pros we get the the top people out there
because real estate business is a
business where people come in and out
like a revolving door depending on uh
how devoted they are to that as a career
but if you're devoted to it as a career
and you're selling large volume you
didn't sit on the sidelines in the last
three months while a lot of people did
that's exactly right I mean but what's
really interesting about this and you
said said this we've talked about this
on the show you know people were shocked
by the increase in rates and then the
minute you start to see a little drop
you had people that were all pent up and
now they're moving and so it's going to
be very interesting to see and and you
it's an election year hello it is and
you explained this to me uh years ago so
I want to tee you up to talk about it
because the FED right now is is kind of
hedging its bets you you see a lot of
different news on it but there's no
guarantee that the FED is going to
actually drop rates they said they're
going to be in a holding pattern but
that doesn't mean they're going to drop
so we may stay where we are but
regardless that's not what is going to
drive the actual mortgage rate it's
people it's the bond market and the
whole mortgages are sold as bonds once
they're packaged together and so the
bond the the interest rate prevailing
interest rate on the bond market is the
mortgage rate that's right period that
drives the mortgage rate the FED has
absolutely no direct connection to
mortgage rates that's right uh the Fed
rate is the rate that Banks borrow money
from each other it's the wholesale money
rate in the industry that's all it is
and so it is not a direct connection but
it does you know it it does uh uh you
know telescope out right you know
Telegraph out where we're going and it's
not unusual with the FED raises rates
you're going to see that bond market
raise rates and when the bond market
raises rates your mortgage rates go up
so that that's what's going on but um
you
know you got to think anything the Biden
Administration can do to put pressure on
the FED to not do that they're going to
do because a president that is in a very
weak precarious political position add a
bad economy to it and you got 100%
chance of non- reelection that's right
there's a lot of speculation so they're
going to do everything they can to get
rates down um and that's not politics
that's just history uh of politics so
yeah right good luck with that yeah good
luck being a president in a trying to
get reelected in either party when the
economy is bad in your watch good luck
with that there's almost zero time that
has happened like I think it is zero do
you have an opinion on if it will be a
long time before we get back to the rat
that we've had over the last five 10
years no economists and weather
forecasters are the only people that can
be wrong all the time and keep their
jobs I love it you're like I'm not
touching that one no I have no idea cuz
I yeah that's I I do know this I do know
this 100% of the time they go up and
down and they've been up a while so
they're kind of due to come down you
know it's really I mean that's you know
it's it's it's always going to go up no
it's not it's going to come back down no
it's always going to go down no it's not
it's going to go back up I mean this the
same with the stock market you know it's
say it's going to move about all we know
is change is coming that's 100%
prediction on change and I don't I
honestly think that anything that any
political pressure that can be brought
any administrative pressure that can be
brought to bring rates down is going to
occur because I mean whoever is running
the Biden administration's not they got
to have a clue that even if someone else
is running in the Democratic party
they're not going to get in If he if
they don't get this straightened out cuz
the the economic situation is dire with
the inflation and with the high interest
rates you got true stagflation going on
open phones atle
88255 225 mogas is with us in Charlotte
hey mogas how are
you good afternoon good how are you
great how can we
help well um I am a new teacher I worked
my first year in
2023 and I recently discover your show
about two months ago so I've changed my
ways uh but I wanted to give you a
little bit of background before I tell
you what my end goal is by now so I a
first generation student I graduated in
2022 uh so I had to take a lot of loans
out and private loans as well to pay for
school because I was decided to be the
first one to graduate in my family how
much Deb do you have honey um so I have
8,000 a private loan that was originally
6,000 and it's still growing but I'm
paying uh monthly now with very high
interest in how much dead do you have
honey uh 28 federal student loan 19,000
a car 5,000 credit card mhm and that's
it okay are you ready to stop borrowing
money because you've been borrowing on
everything in
sight yeah I got a second job and now
I'm paying with that second job what are
you getting paid as a first year teacher
in North
Carolina 38 yeah and you got a $199,000
car you can't
afford right you got student loans
coming out your ears you bought a car
way too
expensive I know that was the first
mistake that I made graduating because I
thought I was a big girl big girl job
and I could afford a car but now I'm
paying it every month and yeah now you
got big girl problems yeah yeah okay
let's get rid of it let's sell the car
and get you a cheap
one yeah I've I've tried to but I'm
scared like No One's Gonna buy it and
well how would we know we've not
tried yeah
oh
uh the path listen listen the definition
of insanity is continuing to do the same
thing over and over again expect a
different result you've been borrowing
on school and Justified that you
borrowed on a car and Justified that you
borrowed on a steak dinner and put it on
a credit card and Justified that some
point you got to quit borrowing and
justifying at some point you got to say
this is stupid and I'm going to go back
to ground zero and start building my
life I make $34,000 a year I'm a first
round teacher and I'm going to pick up
tutoring jobs on the side and double my
income and get these stupid student
loans and credit cards out of my life
cut up the credit cards tonight and sell
the car this
week time to take radical action kiddo
if you want to win that's how you do
it and I'm trying to shock you and break
you loose here cuz where how you grew up
has nothing to do with student loans
it's cuz you didn't work while you're in
school that's why you have student loans
cuz you could have worked your way
through bunch of people do every day
right now so it's okay I'm not mad at at
you but don't walk around justifying
this get it cleaned up now cuz it's
between you and becoming wealthy this is
the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual
amazing relationships Ken Coleman number
one bestselling author of the book
paycheck to purpose host of the Ken
Coleman show Ramy personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America the phone number is
88255 225 Clayton is in Little Rock
Arkansas hey Clayton welcome to the
Ramsey Show Hey sir how are you guys
better than we deserve brother what's up
awesome man well you know first of all I
just want to say it really is an honor
to speak to you guys I'm a huge fan of
the show I've watched countless YouTube
clips Etc and I think you guys are out
there changing Liv so I want to start
off with that well thank you sir how can
we help you
today absolutely well you know I uh I
kind of start from a broad overview and
I'll kind of break it down if that's
okay with you um just you know my my
broad overview question Dave um is
really just how not to get discouraged
in the wealth building process um I'll
give you some background information I'm
27 years old my wife is 30 um we have a
combined net worth of around probably
200,000 or so wow you it's right there
my number thank you and um I make about
58,000 60,000 on my primary job and I do
a side hustle um and but total I make
around 80 to 90 kind of depending on the
year and my wife makes around 72 um the
only anything that we owe on is our home
we both have MBA uh degrees we have no
Consumer Debt no car loans anything like
that um my home is currently worth
probably around
300,000 um and I owe about
195 um we we we have two
kids um and overall life is good um you
know we we're still in the process of
trying to button everything up we're
investing 10% right now I know I need to
get that number to 15 uh my home's on a
15 senior note we're trying to get our
kids college you know all that sit
situated so there's nothing really on
fire uh per se but in
general I really do believe what you
guys teach and I believe you know we we
we give 10% of our income to the church
I mean I'm a really big believer in
living within your means not saying
we're perfect by any means you've done a
great job Clayton I mean your numbers
are amazing for your age way to go you
make $160,000 a year you have no debt
except your house everything's on track
you're killing it
right right well man you know I I I I I
really do believe it and I I appreciate
it but at the same time um like I I
think long term right like I'm but have
you done the
math huh have you done the
math right right yeah yeah if you save
15% of
$160,000 that's going to be a million
dollar in 10 years
dude right right and that's with no
match have you got a match yes sir sir
yes sir do the
math right right well you know man it
just did you do the math no yes sir I
did yes okay then did you see 10 years
you're going to be a millionaire at 20
at 37 years old yes sir yes sir so why
is that
discouraging you know I don't know man I
just like I look at life right and I
know comparison to the thief of joy and
I don't you know I try not to go there
in my head but
comparison if anything you compare to
you should be ahead
of right right right well you know just
I it's okay if I give you some
background some more background
information is that okay okay I'm trying
to understand it's okay I'm trying to
understand why you're discouraged
there's no reason to be I'm I'm really
confused with that because dude you're
in the top 2% of America you're killing
it just I I just think like long term
Dave I think
when I just see how everything is so
expensive and even when I pay off my
home and I have all my retirement
accounts Etc I just you know like I'm
trying to really set my family up so
like in 10 years my daughter will be 13
right and I'm trying to almost get ahead
of the game where I can make sure we can
go on big vacations you know take care
of her college and I realize okay I'll
Be A Millionaire but I just it feels
like everything's so expensive and it's
such a long proc and I realize that you
know wealth isn't obtained easy I'm not
trying to say that but it is it is a
long process 10 10 years is a lot longer
than 10 minutes and most people most
people have the attention span of a
gat why that's why they're not able to
build wealth I I've been I've been
listening Clayton and I I've been where
you are I I actually I I hear me 10
years ago on this phone call so I I just
want to say this your issue is not
comparison your issue is fear and you're
afraid you're not going to be able to do
the things that you would like to do
because you're too stuck in the
headlines and what you're not focusing
on is as Dave has pointed out you're
crushing it number one you're really
ahead of the game this is all going to
compound for you and you're going to be
fine you're going to take some great
vacations but what you're not focused on
is is what you can actually do you're
you're focusing on all these outside
circumstances the economy inflation
whatever else is going on in your head
you do need to quit wiing the news yeah
you need to start focusing on your
income and what what you're going to
make next year and the year after that
and how you're going to be able to make
more money and that you can go out and
determine your financial future you're
already great but you're you're
forgetting in all this headline stuff
and all this fear and comparison here's
what you're forgetting your ability your
wife's ability to put a financial plan
that includes increasing income and
you're going to be able to pay for all
those things yeah your income's aren't
going to be stagnant for the next 10
years absolutely
I don't know if that helps you Clayton
you got to shake all that stuff off
you're inside your head so deep Andor
here the thing the secret to happiness
is low expectations and I'm a little bit
afraid you thought when you made
$160,000 you were going to be rich uh
that's a very good point and you're not
rich at $160,000 with two kids there's
no it's no cake you thought it was going
to be on Easy Street like everything's
going to like you're going to be flying
in a private jet or something and you
know it's 160 Grand you're not so you
got a lot more you got double the
household income of the average American
you're in the top one or 2% of the
average Americans your age with where
you are with no debt and already having
a a positive net worth of a couple
hundred, you are killing it and you
actually are paying attention which puts
you way above almost everyone who walk
around with their heads stuck in the fog
and um that was kind that was I did that
I did that for radio did you hear that
yeah and um yeah I mean that that's
you're incredible you're doing great
you're doing great calm down enjoy the
ride buddy you you really I can't I
can't tell you enough to do this over
and over and over again enjoy the ride I
I want to say one other quick
encouragement because Dave I think
you're absolutely right I just want to
Echo what Dave said we have with all
young generations and throughout history
but even more so now because we're in
the social media era God help us I know
unrealistic expectations lead to unmet
expectations I I can't say that enough I
wish I could preach that message to
every young person well because here's
the deal you nailed it they think when
they get to six figures I thought you
talking about my golf game and your golf
game oh yeah unrealistic expectations
are unrealistic unmet expectations
that's it no I just my golf game is in
the last category just unmet
period it doesn't matter that's what it
is cuz here's the thing when you make a
$100,000 a year you thought it was going
to be easy and when you make a million
dollar a year you thought it was going
to be easy it don't get easy MH it just
gets better than if you don't pay
attention that's all it does this is the
ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for being with
us Chaz is with us in San Antonio Texas
hi Chaz how are you I'm doing pretty
good my question is about what is the
best route I could take to become an
airline pilot and if you allow me uh
here's some quick details about my
situation so I am in my freshman year of
engineering college and my plan is to
get a 4-year mechanical engineering
degree that my parents are willing to
pay for and with that degree I'll get a
job and then pay pay for flight school
with my own money without going into
debt and then on top of that I will have
a engineering degree to fall back on in
the case that I can't fly in the future
for whatever reason however I'm starting
to rethink this plan because I'm sure
you've heard there's a massive pilot
shortage right now and I think it might
be a good opportunity for me to skip
college and go straight into the
Airlines and I would get lots of
benefits
going in immediately I would be in a hot
job market and I would also start my
Aviation career earlier which would get
me something called seniority which is
very very important in the airlines it's
basically the pilot who's been there the
longest has the most job security the
best
pay
and hey Chaz they're just in a really
good position Chaz a couple things
number one uh you can't just go into
being a pilot you're still gonna have to
Fork out a lot of money uh for the
training but I've got a better solution
for you and this is not my opinion this
is from a guy who uh is one of the top
Pilots for FedEx flies all around the
world flies their jumbo Jets met him
over the holidays had coffee with him
here's what he said I I asked him what
would you say to somebody who asked this
question because I get this question a
lot he said and this is a guy who was a
Navy pilot he said I would have a young
person go into the military and you're
going to get paid for the training and
and you're not there's no debt and
they're going to train you as a pilot
and you're gonna have the hours you're
gonna have the hours you get everything
paid for and they pay you they pay you
and you come out of the military and now
you're qualified and ready to go so
skipping College if you wanted to fast
forward uh then go right into the
military but if my mom and dad are going
to pay for a mechanical engineering
degree and that was a fallback plan
that's not a bad plan and then go into
the military uh out of school so I would
say those are the two best options if I
were you based on what I know uh that's
what I would
do okay uh one thing um I can tell you
is it may be wrong information but I'm
pretty sure it's correct I talked to an
airline pilot that lives in my
neighborhood and he told me not to go to
the military route because they can get
you um all the hours that you need but
they can't actually get you the ratings
that you need for the airlines which is
something that you're going to have to
get yourself which will still cost money
and my parents are willing to help me
pay for the um uh Fast Track school to
the airline uh par should
be okay well that's new information uh
you are corre your your friend is
correct your neighbor's correct but
still you're getting Advan you're
advancing yourself in the military
without having to come out of pocket but
if Mom and Dad are willing to pay cash
not going into debt for the for the
training then that's an option so Chaz
um
I if you FasTrack with them you go to
FastTrack School what's that cost how
long does it
take since I already have my private
pilot's license it would cost
$80,000 and my parents would pay for
that partially I'm assuming about half
maybe a little bit less than that and
how long's it
take it would take 9 months and I could
get into the airlines uh very soon
and one thing I would like to mention is
the reason uh I would want to do this is
to get into the market immediately
because the pilot shortage is right now
sure but who's paying for the other 40
if Mom and Dad are paying about half oh
me I would be going into that $440,000 a
debt okay but that's not what you said
earlier so this is now now the story's
changing it was Mom and Dad could pay
for the flight in Fast Track well they
can't they can only pay half well I I
said um partially partially
I would be going into debt yes sir well
we would not recommend that you go into
debt for this when you don't have to
yeah and here's the thing when you come
out with a four-year degree in
mechanical engineering we're talking
about 90 to $100,000 a year exactly when
you come out of $80,000 worth of flight
school you're flying American Eagle for
$335,000 a year
yeah um you know you're in you know I
don't give a crap about the pilot
shortage honey they ain't putting you in
a 727 when you're freaking years old and
you just come out of school and wet
behind the ears they don't do that okay
the guys in the big jets are
old and they don't put the boys in there
they put the little boys in the American
Eagle little Canadian Jets I fly with
them I see what they're doing they're I
got socks older than these guys that are
flying these things and they don't pay
them anything so you need to check your
facts on actual entry on what you do get
paid coming in because you're going to
fly a regional at best prop or jet
and
um and you don't make any money at the
start even if there is a pilot shortage
yeah uh the pilot shortage is a shortage
on the top end stuff not people getting
paid no money doing and if you go the
military route you can save up the money
for your instrumentation and all that
not to mention I I wish I knew this I'll
know this next time uh but I also wonder
if the GI Bill does not maybe go towards
that certification and that education as
well I would tend to believe it does but
I'm not 100% sure I think it probably I
think it would I'm just not 100% sure so
therefore no debt Chaz let me just tell
you working with doing what I'm doing
for 30 years Pilots
are it's a different thing that
activates in people when they decide
they want to be a pilot flying an
aircraft you've got your private you
know this is addictive MH and you guys
you lose your minds in order to get to
fly an
airplane you're willing to jump through
and do anything just to get to fly an
airplane because it's just so stinking
much fun and you know people do
ridiculous things so don't trade a
$100,000 job for a $35,000 job and
$40,000 worth of debt uh don't don't
make that trade yes I please don't just
because of this so uh people get there's
something about the pilot thing that
people they they it's all the only other
one is like being coming a chiropractor
they spend $200,000 to do that you spend
the same $200,000 You' have been an MD
right you you know and instead you're
making $45 $50,000 a year as a
chiropractor and it makes no sense at
all but they get their head gets all
foggy with the the the process of doing
it or whatever I don't know I don't know
what it is it's different it's different
than other careers yeah well just it's a
good career it's a good I'm going to
make good money so we justify it and
again I I there's not good money on the
start there's not there's not good money
on the start there's not there's not at
all cuz cuz there's a bline of these
guys that are addicted to Flying yeah so
yeah there is a pilot shortage but it's
a certain kind of pilot and it's not
entry level I wish you could have heard
this guy Dave he he was a Navy pilot
straight out of Annapolis Navy pilot for
20 years flew combat missions and now
he's flying the biggest jet FedEx has
and he was in F he was like tell people
tell young people they have a great
career if they go the military route and
they're not going to go into debt and
they're going to be able to pay for it
he was very emphatic about it well yeah
you fly with an you fly with a pilot and
you know their military you can tell
when they land yeah that's
right they don't they're not worried
about soft right right that is true they
put him down oh you yeah that guy was he
was Navy yeah that guy that guy was Air
Force yeah oh this guy he he didn't fly
he didn't fly luxury Charters I don't
think right right well they land on an
aircraft carrier I mean guess
unbelievable talking about that in the
middle of the ocean Chaz go Live Your
Dream buddy but don't turn it into a
nightmare that's all we're saying so uh
if you were my son I would tell you to
finish your mechanical engineering
degree and then work on your pilot stuff
and I would consider the military route
if you're my son that's what I tell you
to do so that's the summation of the
call we appreciate you calling in open
phones at
225 started a long time ago when people
started saying Live Your Dream Live Your
Dream Live Your Dream Ken and people
will then justify that and turn their
dreams into a nightmare if they're not
real careful so true and it happens all
the time it's the Trap and the trap is
this I want it now and I've never seen a
dream that was worthy that you got now
or that you got fast change your mindset
on that and then you'll be able to avoid
the Temptation philosophy 101 Ken
Coleman this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything cost too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for for over a decade so you
know you can trust them from blinds
drapes and shutters to motorized Shades
they make it easy and affordable to
upgrade your entire home and their team
is ready to help with everything from
design consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 45% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today all right I got a question
for you folks out there how long does it
take you to pay off a credit
card that has a $5,000
balance with an APR of
16% which in the credit card world is a
good
deal if you pay $100 a month minimum
payment which is the T average
requirement on
that $5,000 16% $100 minimum
payment
answer 6 years and 11
months and you pay $3,200 in interest on
the $5,000 while you do
it can anyone spell stupid in math I
just
did that's stupid in math
spell I just spelled stupid for you in
math it's pretty good
seriously and yet we all walk around
well I get airline miles oh my God
you're so
stupid discover gives me a dollar back
for every $100 I spend oh my God you're
stupid I've never met a millionaire that
said Dave you know I made all my money
with my airline
miles it doesn't come up man it just
doesn't come up the problem is you get
stuck in a cycle of this stuff and it's
so freaking hopeless like the student
loans they're hopeless it's like a pile
of Mount Everest of debt and I don't
know how I'm going to climb and I'm
stuck in a cycle of debt I'm stuck in a
cycle of stupid Financial stuff that's
out there and did you know that stupid
has a gravitational pull and you can't
break loose from it it'll hold you into
the orbit you just keep orbiting around
and around and around stupid you know
how you break an orbit massive
energy you have to expend massive energy
to break an orbit so if you're stuck in
the cycle you can kick the year off
we're hosting a free live stream one
week from today on Thursday January the
11th at at 7 Central it's our officially
our largest live stream over ever over
250,000 people have already signed up to
watch it it's completely free it's
called Break the side
break the cycle break the orbit off of
stupid you are not stuck your family
curse is not your problem the
neighborhood you grew up in is not your
problem you need some more information
and some more inspiration and we can
show you how to break the cycle we've
done it for millions of people so me
Rachel Cruz George camel Jade washaw Dr
John deloney we're going to be doing
break the cycle talking about navigating
the money anxiety bad money habits and
keep you stuck practical money tips that
actually work how to break the
cycle because you're stuck and we're
going to give away
$1,000 10 times
$10,000 to people that are viewing there
is no purchase necessary but you must be
a viewer not having just signed up to
watch and so we want you to watch we
want to help you we want to change your
life we want to give you the information
and the inspir operation it's called
hope break the cycle so what do we do we
go to ramsy solutions.com SL break the
cycle and you sign up for the free live
stream it's going to be 7:00 Central
Time Thursday January the 11th and I'm
guessing at this stage of the game we're
probably going to have close to 400,000
people maybe even 500 viewing so thank
you thank you for your response already
and thank you for those of you that are
going to respond after I just did this
cuz you are not
stuck but I will promise you I've been
there stupid has a gravitational pull
and if you continue to do the same thing
over and over again and expect a
different result that's the definition
of insanity you have got if you don't
like the cake change the recipe I don't
like chocolate cake quit using that
recipe and then scratching your head
while you're getting chocolate cake it's
how it works you got to change something
if you want something to change and
we're going to show you how baby we love
you enough to coach you we love you
enough to encourage you we even love you
enough to get up in your face because we
want you to win and we've proven it 30
years of doing this so come join us
Ramsey solutions.com
breakthe cycle Matt is in Knoxville hey
Matt how are you hey Dave thanks for uh
taking my call I just had a quick baby
step question with my own variables
throwing in if you don't mind sure um so
I have these two credit cards one is at
2200 one's at 6,800 um I make 56 Grand a
year uh usually comes out in my check
about
$3,500 when those are all set in done I
got about $800 to spend or live life
with essentially um and on top of this I
have a beautiful girlfriend in medical
school and I'm looking to buy her a ring
and um one thing I did last last year
was I maxed the match with my retirement
at 7% I think so my retirement got up to
like n Grand and obviously with this
credit card debt I'm thinking I couldn't
have afforded to do that so I took that
down to
3% um into my retirement to have the
extra money to go to um the ring and
whatnot and my credit card debt and so
I'm just kind of curious in my situation
I'm also looking to gain income I got
some side hustles in the works to gain
income and get a new job too you're
25 yeah I turned 26 so that's the other
thing I'm I'm diabetic so I'm going to
have to pay for my own insurance and uh
not cheat when you're diabetic juvenile
diabetes or adult uh type yeah juvenile
okay all right man okay um so what do
you do for a
living uh fundraising okay all right so
you're doing what most people do and we
we discovered a long time ago doesn't
work and that's trying to do six things
at once and none of them get done right
you're getting no traction
nowhere everything's half asked follow
me yes sir yeah so what I'm going to
change is just tell you to get totally
focused on one thing first do you have
any money
saved 500 bucks when are you going to
pop the
question uh six months you wait six
months to pop the
question you said don't wait I said are
you going to wait six months to pop the
question did I understand you right
that's a long time yes sir that's the
longest that's the longest I'll wait
okay all right so we well we need a game
plan here to lay out to save for this
all right so here's what I would tell
you to do I would stop all
saving okay stop everything all right
did you get a tax refund last
year uh my taxes were screwed up I have
to redo it this year
okay so you don't know because I don't
think you're taking home enough I don't
know if the $ 3500 was after $99,000
coming out if it was after $9,000 coming
out then that's about right but if it's
not then there's something else wrong
but anyway so I want to take all we can
home without creating a tax problem and
I want to stop all
401K temporarily and focus on the first
goal is get $1,000
saved okay okay the second goal is pay
off the $2,200 credit card and cut them
both up tonight by the way okay plastic
surgery no screwing around with those
things anymore they you in the
butt and you need to throw them out the
front
door right all right now then there the
2200 is gone then I want you to save for
a ring how much you going to spend on
the
ring uh about two G okay so if I'm
understanding right I need a 500 bucks
to finish my thousand I need 2200 plus
two so I need 5,000 bucks to get the
credit card paid off the ring and have
my $1,000 saved right
right okay you right now have $800 in
your sort of budget but your sort of
budget sucks so you're going to do a
real budget where you make every dollar
behave every dollar is going to scream
I'm going to give you an app called
every dollar it's the world's best
budgeting app and I'm going to put you
into Financial Peace University our
nine-week class on how to handle money
and I'm going to pay for it you're a
hero now you're going to be the hero
you're going to go do this crap cuz what
you're going to do is hard you're not
going out to eat you're not going on
vacation you're going to take the side
hle and you're going to have five grand
done in two months two months man yes
sir yes sir no one credit card down ring
bought and $1,000 in the bank and then
once the Ring's bought we go back to the
BET de snowball and knock that other
credit card out and we're game on and
I'll show you how to do the rest of it
in financial pieace University it's
called the baby steps you're going to
win you're just the guy we work you're
the guy why I'm here I love where you
are you're a great guy you just need
somebody to show you how to do it I'm
the guy hold on Austin's going to pick
up we'll put you into Financial Peace
and get you in the every dollar app my
[Music]
gift
[Applause]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today the Ramsey Show question
of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for home services
from repairs and maintenance to Home
Improvement projects winter brings some
challenges for homeowners you need to
check out neighbor's helpful winter
checklist which you can download for
free check it out at neighbor.com
Ramsey it's an incredible company
neighbor.com
Ramsey today's today's question comes
from Kelly in Ohio I'm 23 and about a
year out of ministry school with no
school debt since I work four jobs and
cash flowed everything so I'm totally
debt free way to go Kelly I work at a
professional Screen Printing and
embroidery shop and volunteer for
Ministry making $20 an hour I work 45
hours a week at the shop and after taxes
I'm at about 30 36,000 a year this is
the most I've ever made but when I
listen to the show I'm often confused at
what you all say is a good income to me
this is good income since I'm able to
save $1,100 a month towards a down
payment on a house what are your
thoughts do I need to be worried about
getting another job or is it about how
I'm budgeting all right a lot of
questions here first thing that comes to
mind is why do we go to Ministry
School uh you know if we go to Ministry
School and we've changed our mind fine
with that but if we went to Ministry
School to be in the ministry I'd want to
know what the path is uh to Ministry and
then once you get into Ministry depends
on what you're doing because people
don't go into Ministry to make money at
least the people that are actually about
Ministry so the question about good
income I think it's a a tad bit relative
but if you look at the uh the income
scale in the United States 36,000 is is
is obviously on the low side uh but I
love your discipline that you actually
have a budget and that on that income uh
because you have no debt and you're
living on less than you make uh you know
look you're saving some pretty good
money there so uh I don't think you need
to be worried about getting another job
no but the answer to that is what job do
I go to next because I doubt that you
want to be in this screen printing and
embroidery embroidery business for the
rest of your life so if I was sitting
with you I'd say what's our long-term
plan or what are a couple options that
we are considering for the long term and
what I'm talking about there are
destinations and once we have an idea on
some destinations we can start to choose
direction direction is always more
important than destination uh because
the destination tends to change but
direction will get us going and making
progress so uh you're doing a great job
on budgeting and as you increase your
income with the way you budget the more
you save the more you can invest yeah
that's the proper answer to your
question also hidden in your question
was you didn't like it that we said
36,000 wasn't a good income good income
is not a moral statement right good
income is relative to the average
household income in America which is
78,000 right
now and so if you make 36 as a single
person just out of school you are
considerably less than the average which
would also make up the average and
that's okay it's not the end of the
world it's not a you're not a bad person
you're not a horrible income earner
you're not lazy none of those are
judgments that are say when we say good
income all we're saying is relative to
the average yours is
low but somebody's got to make up the
average so the question is do you want
it to be you and so you know you start
thinking about where you want to be in
10 years if you're just out of school
let's call you 23 what do you want the
33 year old version of you to look
like detail it out Ken just told you to
determine the the direction the
destination and then let's move towards
that rather than landing and being
satisfied and say well I've got margins
so I call this a good income even if you
all don't well our our portion is not
that you can't live on it I think you're
doing a great job you're amazing you're
doing a great job with your budgeting
but your income is below average that's
another way of saying it exactly rather
than saying a good income but so when
someone calls us and says they make you
know
$160,000 that's double
the national average and so that by
definition is a good income it's above
average way above average and so these
days when you make six figures you're
above average the old days when you made
six figures you were called Rich but
nowadays you just can buy Alpo but you
know it's there you go but that that's
the thing I mean
so you know because Alpo have you seen
the prices no I'm kidding but so the
thing is Kelly that that you are doing a
good job and you're not spiritually or
psychologically wrong to be satisfied
right now with where you are however as
a person that tells you you know we want
to be anything that's not growing is
dying so let's be let's be something
that's growing must be aiming at
something and have a destination
Dustin's in Kansas City hi Dustin
welcome to the ramsy show hey Dave how's
it going better than I deserve man
what's up oh no hey I talked to you and
Ken back in 2021
my income was considerably low to where
I'm making now and I'm just trying to
get some guidance on what house price is
reasonable for my income and then also
what my fiveyear plan should be real
quick tell us what you were making when
you called us and what you're making now
so when I called you guys I was making
46,000 and that was just my main job now
I'm making 100,000 60 of that being
salary 40 of it being in bonuses within
the last two years well done sir and and
then also my son business that I've been
running this year was a major major jump
and I made 125,000 just on that alone
that Ken Coleman guy when you call him
he's amazing yeah right you had
everything that's amazing way to go stud
wow proud that's excellent yeah that's
great income you have a good income yeah
there we said it
again by the way not our opinion just
the
stats yeah and you guys are my only gu
it's I'm 24 years old so now my age give
good advice so I'm just trying to so
you're making a couple of hundred yeah
this year you know it might not happen
next year I dad gum man impressive how
can the world can we help you so
currently right now if I sold my
inventory that I have I would have
$125,000 I paid cash for a car this year
which was 30,000 and then I paid cash
for land that was 65,000 wow so I got
that all paid off the only debt I have
right now is $119,000 500 on my house um
the house back when I called it was a
flip house I didn't intend on living in
it but I got comfortable and I'm still
comfortable just because my mortgage is
750 and that's my only debt but me and
my wife are going to look at a house
tonight it's 335,000 and you know going
from a $750 mortgage to potentially
1,500 I just it scares me so I just want
to make sure that's okay before I just
jump into anything it's
okay okay you got it dude yeah yeah
you're good put it on 15year fixed and
then pay it off as fast as you can keep
working the plan you've been working
it's amazing when you aim at something
how you hit it m and you're you're a
great example when you start aiming at
something everything started
changing and you just had a very clear
vision of where you wanted to go and
you've gotten there even faster than you
dreamed you were going to and very
impressive so um yeah put it on 15E
fixed and here's the thing you marry the
house and you date the rate
the rates are the rates are up over
where they were three years ago everyone
that's breathing knows that uh but
they're down over where they were 10
years ago so um I don't know what the
rates are going to do but let's pretend
they came down after you bought this
house you
refinance you date the rate but you buy
the house you marry the house so we're
not buying a house it's temporary
because of this real estate market and
these interest rates we're buying a
house that's a good house that we're
going to live in a while great house you
marry the house and date the rate and
then you go ahead and get the interest
rate make sure it's less than a fourth
of your take-home Pace still on a
15-year fixed and it will be with what
you're describing you've done a great
job you're doing good and here's a
beautiful thing too as long as you'll
stay a little
nervous a little nervous not anxious but
a little nervous the ner that kind of
nerves is called caution and some people
call it wisdom mhm Way Beyond your 24
years that you're not just out spending
like you're in Congress trying to keep
up with some on Tik
Tok so yeah that that that makes you a
super impressive 24 year old yeah and I
Dave I want you to comment on this but I
tried to take myself back to When Stacy
and I bought our first house and I think
it was 195,000 and I thought how'd you
get the dinosaur
out I but but I remember like but it was
based on the ratios and what we did is
we went back to the ratios that you've
been teaching 30 years and we were able
to afford it you can't focus on how much
the mortgage payment's going up focus on
the fact that it's well within the ratio
of what you can afford and then your
mind adjusts to the increase exactly I
think that's what helped us well and the
house is going to go up and your
income's going to go up and you're going
to be fine yeah yeah you're going to be
all right it's all going to work out way
to go man good job man I love it this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
oh
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
America we're so glad you're here Ken
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today he's the author of the number one
bestselling book from paycheck to
purpose and he's host of the Ken Coleman
podcast which is unbelievably popular
helping people with their jobs their
money their career make more money and
enjoy everything a little better so he's
helping today you jump in we'll talk to
him me all of us8
8255 225 Katherine starts this hour off
in Detroit hey Katherine how are
you hi Dave and Ken thank you so much
for taking my call sure um I am seeking
advice today on my relationship okay um
I've been dating my boyfriend for almost
a year um and things have been going
really well but I have concerns that as
you know things continue to progress
hopefully down the path towards marriage
that our discrepancy in finances um
specifically income debt retirement
savings um will be a problem um and that
ultimately I might kind of find myself
in in a sugar mama type situation which
I'd really um you don't want be that
girl yeah we already have a problem yeah
I love it good for you so uh how old are
you I'm 38 and he 35 okay cool and what
do you make I make 200 and he makes 45
okay all right and what does he
do um he works in construction M and
what do you
do uh I work in the automotive industry
okay there is nothing wrong with
anything you've told me so far that uh
makes us incompatible as long as you're
both in agreement so what we've found is
there's four things that um good
research is revealing that that if you
agreed on four things prior to marriage
you have a very high statistical
probability of staying married number
one is money how we handle it how we
view it okay number two cuz money fights
and money problems number one cause a
divorce so you got to deal with it so
you're smart to call a money show and
talk about this number two uh kids are
we going to have them how many how we
going to treat them are the inmates
going to run the Asylum that kind of
stuff right number three the crazy
people on our family called in-laws
because everybody's got crazy in their
family and you don't think it's you
don't think you do it's
you so you everybody's got it so how we
going to handle that how we going to
handle the extended crazy and and are we
going to stand beside each other in that
and number three is religion agreement
on religion and so if you're in
agreement on those four things you have
a very high probability let's go back to
the money one a minute you obviously are
a high income earner and he's obviously
a construction guy out there doing it
and but and yet you're falling in love
and that's cool all right uh that's not
my concern my concern would be his view
towards his debt how much debt has he
got and how does he view
it so he has um around about
50,000 um and um and when we started
dating I gave him the Total Money
Makeover um and he read it and I have
seen him change his spending Behavior
his you know started budgeting um really
trying to you know save and attack debt
so he bought into the idea that debt is
bad and he wants to get rid of
it yes and you think that is bad and you
want to get rid of it so you're aligned
on that I'm yeah I'm completely debt
free baby step six I'm not talking about
where you are I'm talking about what you
believe you both believe dead is bad and
you want to get rid of it aligned yes
okay then that that's the important
thing so what are you worried about if
he says if he says oh baby it ain't no
problem I'm just going to work till
Friday and I don't I'm gonna buy I'm
gonna get me a new truck whenever I want
to don't marry
him but he's not saying that I'm worried
about
no he's not what
I'm worried is just or maybe need to
kind of come to to grips with is you
know I've worked really hard to be in
the financial situation I'm in because
i' I followed you all for um you know
most of my adult life and now we're
talking about you know what this would
entail would be ultimately taking on
someone else's debt cuz I don't see any
ways getting out of it you know in the
next few years no you're going to marry
him and he's going to have debt you're
going to pay it off well wait a second
why why wait a second wait wait wait
what's wrong with that I I have a quick
question what what makes you think that
it's going to take him two years or so
to get I mean $50,000 if he gets serious
and he is in alignment he can get rid of
this debt you don't have to necessarily
marry all of it I I think if he's
aligned what I'd want to know is is how
gazelle intense is he willing to get and
stay that way and stay that way so that
you don't marry much if any first of all
we he hadn't even put a ring on it
listen ifen if he had $200,000 worth of
debt and he's plowing through it and you
marry into it I'm okay yeah as long as
yall are aligned I'm getting rid of it
that's the thing you got to be what's
what will kill you is not being aligned
not having unless you just get all
twisted up and bothered inside your head
and go like I did him a favor and he
owes me the rest of his life now that's
on you but but if you're willing to just
throw in and say all right it's all in
everything's in the middle and we're all
going to get rid we're going to use my
assets your my debt your debt it's all
hours now we're going to clean it up and
we're going to live for the rest of our
lives the way you've been living so far
then you've got a good marriage
match I think that sounds good I think
that's a good point yeah but if you if
you're having to drag his butt along mhm
because he's going to misbehave and he's
going to I've always you know everybody
has a car payment crap who needs that
garbage you know you don't you don't
want be that that is then you're you're
signing up for a problem yeah my concern
and again I'm not saying this is this
guy but there's a difference between
somebody believing something and doing
something yeah I'd like to see him I
want he's starting to take action on his
new beliefs and as long as he does that
and he's really you know he's taking two
extra jobs and he's attacking this debt
and this may be a great may be a great
find he's a great guy he just needed
some you know he just needed some
somebody show him the path right I think
it's a great test too not that she says
it that way and she doesn't position
that way but if you if you're willing to
say yes to this guy I think you being
willing to say yes if he proposes is
based on you laying down the tough
conversation now while we're dating see
what we don't want to do is have the
tough difficult money conversations
after we've gotten engaged or after
we've gotten married I think at this
point what you've laid out seems like
he's a good guy and it seems like
there's alignment but now Dave is when I
think we have the difficult conversation
and she goes this is how I want to live
and I'm going to marry a guy who
believes in living this way and what you
want to married into is a shared Vision
not not a messed up past correct that's
right everybody's got a messed up past
that's right so we're marrying into a
shared vision of where we're going yeah
and so I I don't mind if you marry
somebody who was an alcoholic for 10
years but they've been dry for three
years Ag and they've changed their life
I don't count the I don't count the
previous against them yep I count where
we're going is way more important than
where we've been y
and so you know where we're going where
are we going and are we going to go
together and is it going to we're going
to be in agreement if I have to fight
you all the time about borrowing money
about saving money I'm not going to be
on that's not that's not that's not an
alignment but if we're on if we're
aligned on that and I just got a head
start on you oh that's okay that's okay
this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
well for the first time in the Ramsey
show history a couple of weeks ago we
hit number one out of all podcasts on
Apple in the entire world thank you and
you did that uh we appreciate you you
did that because you have followed
instructions when we told you to
subscribe because that helps us uh to
follow to share the show to give us a
five-star review we really appreciate
you doing that thank you very much can
continue listen if you like it share it
follow it
subscribe and leave us a festar it's
very helpful to us we really really
appreciate it because it changes the
algorithms that are used with the with
the different podcast platforms Apple
included and that's how we end up number
one on Apple so thank you guys we really
really really app appreciate it uh and
podcast reviews are coming in these are
cute thank you just started out on the
baby steps and the show offers such
great motivation the personalities on
the show all compliment each other very
well enjoyable to listen to hearing
debt-free churns is a huge source of
Hope and encouragement grateful I found
it from Tanya thank you Tanya we're
grateful ruining my life how do you know
it's working when your spouse says Dave
Ramsey's ruining my
life all inest but it's definitely
working from coupon Clipper thank you
way to go and thanks from the UK love
the and the principles you adhere to
they work just as well over the pond in
the UK I love it you've changed my mind
on how I view debt and how I invest so
I'm starting a new Journey today which
means no more car loans or leases
maximize tax efficient savings and smash
at least 15% in the pinion thanks from
hos way to go hos I like the way he said
that or she said that smash the 15% in
savings like you got to love UK I I love
that very good there's some passion some
intentionality in that Mason is in
Charlotte North Carolina hey Mason
what's up in your
world I'm doing good how are you doing
Mr Ramsey better than I deserve sir how
can we
help hey uh I'm just calling I'm 21 and
I've been working at the same job for
since I got out of high school and I've
kind of lost all sense of passion and
pride and what I do and um I'm really
struggling to find some sort of some
sort of path to be on you know and I
understand that nobody can tell me what
will make me happy um but I've kind of
lost all sense of passion and I'm
calling you for some guidance in the
sense of Ken Coleman 21y Old Clay on the
wheel yeah do your thing man well I want
to start with you said you lost the
passion that implies that at one point
you had some is that true it
is take me back to when you absolutely
loved what you're doing and why you love
yeah I want to hear that um I think it
was a sense of just something new in my
life something like a different world
outside of what I had already lived
through and that being like the the type
of job I do with being a machinist and
seeing different stuff come in every
single day yeah um and it's just it's
kind of slipped away from me and I've
lost that that sort of passion so you
love the newness and I would guess the
challenge with that as
well yes you're good with your hands and
able to see things be in in your mind
before you make
them yes I would say so so have you lost
the challenge have you getting new stuff
or now you've seen all the new stuff and
so there's nothing new anymore is that
what's happening not necessarily that
I've lost the challenge the challenge is
there every day it's just a sense of you
know accomplishment and pride I've kind
of I feel like I've gotten stuck in a a
sort of rat race you know like a being
like a cog in a
machine and I've done things to like
kind of help maybe spark New Passion um
like I've been streaming on
Twitch um pretty regularly and I
actually I really enjoy that but you
know it's not it's not going anywhere
yeah well well the question is what are
you streaming are you streaming like uh
working with your hands and projects
like that what are you
streaming uh just I mainly play video
games my free time all right so that's
really it all right so let me let me
help you out so there was this time when
you really enjoyed uh the working with
your head and your hands the the
building the repairing all of that and I
think what you're facing right now is
you are looking for the next mountain to
climb and I do think this is a natural
progression for somebody who's 21 you've
been doing this three years or so and so
here's the question I've got for you I I
don't want you to overthink it all right
I I want you to tell me what cuz work
solves problems all work provides a
solution which is essentially solving
some problem what are the problems that
you most get excited about when you
think about work and and your abilities
because there's a tie between what
you're good at which we know and what
you love so what problems or Solutions
get you excited when you think about
work I think it's it's it's the biggest
thing would be providing you know a
general help you know like feeling
needed and feeling wanted all right
let's stop right there that's really
good now let's go back to what you do
best if I interviewed all of your shop
teachers coaches parents uncles
everybody and bosses and I said what's
Mason best at doing what would they say
your super talents are and don't be
modest here and don't try to word this
and any there's no wrong answer just
tell me what would they tell
me it would probably just be like doing
what I'm told without questioning it
sounds really bad to say but no but what
I okay let me let me put it this way
there's four types of work there's
people work it's what Dave and I do
we're in the people work business uh
there's ideal work that's what Dave and
I do people and ideas there's process
work okay those are your operations
people accountants you know that kind of
process stuff and then there's then
there's things or objects and those are
people that build fix invent you you
tracking with me yes all right so what
what are which one of those areas or two
are do you have the most talent in
people ideas process or objects I would
say the things and people per like I
enjoy connecting with other people
perfect that ties into the earlier
answer you gave us where you just want
to add value to people right and right
now all you're doing is things that's
right no people in this that's right so
I'm not I'm not hanging any of these
these ideas on you but this is where
your brain's got to go I got to go where
am I gifted if I'm gifted at building or
repairing are are things of that nature
fixing wiring connecting if that's what
I'm really good at and I love doing it
for people then that could be Plumbing
HVAC it could be even the trades where
you can make a killing in today's
economy and eventually be on a path to
owning your own small business I don't
want to project that on you but that's
where the ideation comes from I'm good
with my hands and my head what are you
making as a machinist how much do you
make uh uh post tax or pre-tax I'm sorry
it it's about 40 to 45 I work 50 hours a
week and that fluctuates from $45,000 a
year yes okay all right all right yeah I
I would be interviewing some people that
are in trades that that do stuff that
you're good
at and and ask them about the people
quotient ask them about what they love
about the job and and how they see their
work making people's lives better I
think that's a good starting point for
you because at 21 you don't have a ton
of life experience what you need are
ideas and the ideas are validated when
you go I'm good at that and I would
really enjoy that once I've truly
unpacked what goes into it does that
make sense Mas I think we need to give
him here I'm going to give you the
assessment I want to give you the get
clear assessment it's going to give you
a purpose statement that becomes
essentially a high level job description
I'm also going to give you my book from
paycheck to purpose which is like the
guide to climb the mountain or pursue
the mountains you want to go after
that's my gift but practically speaking
you're not stuck you just don't have
some ideas that you're either confident
in or you just don't have any ideas at
all does that make sense it does and I
definitely do feel like a sense of being
stuck yeah and um I I I I feel like it
also might be a regional thing as well
because I live in a very in a rural area
in North Carolina um but that kind of
touches based on like another thing that
I wanted to bring up with you know if
you were in this position if at this age
with the knowled this goes for both of
you um if you were in this at this age
with the knowledge that you have now
that you where you've gotten to where
you are what would you tell yourself
then I want to figure out what I am what
I am at 10 years from now and get about
the business of getting there yeah and
right now you're just you're just doing
the same thing over and over you're
stuck in a wheel yeah so I want you to
aim at the mountain 10 years from now
and then go climb it so hold on we're
going to help you with the assessment
and with Ken's book brother I appreciate
you calling you're a sharp young guy
this is a ramsy
[Music]
show
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America in the lobby of ramsy Solutions
on the debt free stage Shan and Kathleen
are with us happy New Year guys Happy
New Year New Year how are y'all doing
well how about yourself better than I
deserve where do you live Boston
Massachusetts very cool all the way down
to Nashville Tennessee oh yeah well
welcome it's so good to have you and how
much debt have you guys paid off we paid
off
$147,000 yay how long did that take
about four years good for you and uh
what was your range of income during
that four years we uh we our range was
from 48 to 184,000 well there's a nice
jump
so what do youall do for a living I'm a
firefighter and a ramsy preferred coach
okay and I am a teacher Aid and um a
full-time nursing student okay so what
happened to cause your income to go up
so
much uh a lot has happen uh we went
everything from being unemployed to
working the gig economy and then working
at my was I worked myself
into um Amazon operations manager and
then from there while was doing that I
had uh the GI bill paid for me to go to
school and so you went went to fire okay
yep and then after that I went and got
joined the uh fire department as well
yeah yeah wow good for you Wow way to go
guys this is a great journey so what
kind of debt was the 147,000 oh it was
everything so we had student loans we
had a solar loan we had personal loans
credit cards car loans you normal all
the normal stuff normal yeah and normal
sucks yes it does way to go guys so how
long you guys been
married we just celebrated 13 years
earlier this year so after 9 years of
marriage iall looked up and said 147,000
this is not working something's got to
change what happened tell us the story
what got this started on the Ramsey
stuff it was actually even before that
so we started probably back in about
2014 um it came down to this also that
happened when I was in the Marine Corps
um I was we did the normal thing we took
out a bunch credit cards racked it all
the way up um and then we had basically
the choice of do we pay the mortgage
this month or do we eat right so we had
we knew something had to change at that
point so we went and my mom flew out and
she gave us your book cuz she Googled
how to do a budget that's basically all
she knew about you she was like oh this
guy knows something about budgeting so
we did we did the budget and then we
went through FPU and then we did just
enough change to breathe breathe and
that was it we were Dave is for about
four years okay and then what what got
you on fire what kicked it into gear um
it was the I deserve mentality so when I
when I was working it was after the
Marine Corps when I was working in a
private wealth banking job I got
promoted and at that point I was like
well hey I deserve a truck and so the
$650 payment that we came with it kind
of slapped Us in the face again you know
cuz I'm stubborn and sometimes I need a
2x4 to the Head to you know really get
things moving so once we had that $650
payment we were like well again
something needs to change so here we are
again here we are again you know right
in the wheel right so we went back went
through FPU again and then we got real
intentional about it at the end of 2019
when we started so you got a C minus or
a D+ the first time so you had to retake
it pretty much take the course we had to
retake it okay I'm in I'll take it
yep yep and then so we in
2019 we saw something going on with the
with the company that I was working for
and stuff like that so we actually
paused the baby steps this is why it
took a little bit longer than than we
wanted it to yeah um we saved up a bunch
of cash sure enough 2020 came around
covid lost my job and so right after
that I didn't we had the savings to rely
on but we really went and got you know I
I did all the jobs I had did did I did
the instacart the Shi I did door Dash I
donated white blood cells everything wow
everything out of control yeah and to
survive and not have to hit the savings
Y and then now you've settled into good
solid careers both of you and uh and now
you're dead free that's right proud of
you guys way to go thank you thank you I
just curious about your mindset over the
four-year period so once you actually
recommit and get after it uh I I always
like to know were there moments where
you just didn't think you could could
make it any longer if so I see you
shaking your head uh Kathleen take take
us there I want cuz I think there's some
people that are probably on this journey
they're not where you are today and they
feel like quitting we're not going to
get there what did you do what did you
guys do how did you not quit yeah well
we abolutely we leaned into each other a
lot um there were times when I felt like
giving up and he was like the person
that was like no honey we got this we
got this and there were times when he
was working so many gigs and was tired
he come home so tired and he was just
like I don't know if I can do this I'm
like no babe you're doing so much we're
almost there there was a lot of like
late late night
conversations um kind of like putting
our minds back on what is the goal what
is our end goal cuz if we lose sight of
that that's kind of like when our
motivation would like go down yeah um it
but it was definitely hard sometimes the
kids would be like I want to be like my
friends they're going out tonight I want
to go buy this and it was hard to say no
to them but we had we also had to
explain to them like what we're trying
to to do for our family so that we won't
have to say no in the future and and
they understand for about 10 minutes and
then they ask again of course of course
especially the younger ones yes but our
kids were pretty good we we kind of like
brought them along in our journey and um
they knew what was going on and what we
really good to watch their hero parents
yes probably has their parents are
heroes I'm so proud of y'all they're a
part of our budget so like they knew
what we were doing so yeah yeah they
have their own little chore charts and
everything so very good okay all right
um the the biggest thing that kind of
really pushed us through was you know
seeing things actually work the way that
they're supposed to right so when we
were going through you know you can do
anything for a season right you guys say
that often right and I'm kind of a prime
example at one point when I was working
at Amazon I would so Monday Tuesday
Wednesday I would work at Amazon from
2:00 a.m. to 2:00 p.m. and then I would
come home do some school work go to
school come back do some more school
work and then go back to work so I did
not actually sleep Monday Tuesday or
Wednesday wow and then I did that for I
don't know two and a half months or so
wow so I just you can do anything for a
season for a short period of time you
can do anything absolutely yeah way to
go gosh was it worth it yes yes
absolutely what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is for I
think it's important to be on the same
page in communication cuz I mean this
journey is not for the faint of heart
like you have to really like lean into
each other and um understand each other
where you guys coming from yeah
consistency and uh and Grace right so
because you're going to you're going to
mess up at some point right you have to
be able to not just kind of give up
after you've messed up once right and
then once you've cheated on your diet
once oh I'm never going to do it again
right it's we have to go back into it
and go yeah we messed up how do we avoid
that next time yeah and just keep
pushing very good way to go guys way to
go very proud of you we've got the live
and give box for you to say thanks for
coming from Boston to do your debt free
Scream It's the baby steps millionaire
book because that's the the journey
you're on for sure Total Money Makeover
book to give away when somebody says I
need a budget like your mom did right
and uh to Financial Peace University and
that uh you can go through it twice if
you need to we prove that so we got that
for you you can give that to somebody
it'll help you do that so bring the
kiddos up and give us their names and
ages all right so there's m right here
she's 11 years old there's Evelyn who is
n and there's William who is six wow
goodlooking family oh they're worth it I
believe absolutely yeah good good work
good work you guys very cool I'm so
proud of you congratulations thank you
all right Shan and Kathleen Kathleen I'm
sorry Madeline Evelyn and William from
Boston
Mass 147,000 paid off in four years a
lot of unbelievable hard work living
like no one else so lzy they can live
and give like no one else income from 48
all the way up to 184 during that time
count it down let's hear a de free
scream all right you guys ready 3 2 one
we
Dee
yeah meline Evelyn William got it I like
it yeah that was well done kiddos they
practiced score this is the Ramsey
[Music]
go
yeah